a guy is pushing me off of him
to a stranger with no mask on looking up
at me [ __ ] terrified oh my god dude
[Music]
this
story is the number one craziest thing
that's ever happened by far this is very
viable and i keep waiting for the
[ __ ] cops to call me you know what i
mean okay so
um
i'm flying alone and you know me how
like nervous am i to fly zero right
exactly zero percent nervous like i fly
a lot i never get nervous i'm just like
whatever we take off i [ __ ] fall
asleep before and i don't even notice we
took off
for whatever reason
i get i get there the flight [ __ ]
early because they're like get the early
get they're really good early because
customs takes so long custom takes me 12
minutes it never takes long dude and
there's like one every 20 times but the
fest people were like warning me warning
me right right
so i'm like okay i guess i gotta [ __ ]
anyway i get there in like i'm like
either three hours early wow and i'm
just waiting waiting [ __ ] waiting
waiting waiting waiting so dad and
finally we get on the plane then we're
waiting on the plane yeah and the time's
going going on i got a buddy picking me
up on the other end i'm like i don't
know i'm just getting like antsy and i'm
i'm just realizing the limited space
around me i'm in an exit row but it's
not enough space
okay
and uh i'm just like i'm like my knees
tapping and i'm noticing myself getting
more and more anxious wow and i'm just
like ugh all right at least if we just
take off
you'll be on your way exactly so
five minutes 10 minutes 20 minutes pass
finally we take off like 30 40 minutes
after we we're supposed to
we're in the air
and i'm good yeah
i fall asleep
i wake up
[Music]
and i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah i bet we're
almost we're almost back in l.a i look
at this the flight map thing okay and
it's and it's three hours and 11 minutes
left okay so we're not even close well
you fell asleep for [ __ ] four hours
two hours okay two and a half hours
right so a little a little less than
halfway how far away okay
so i
he's laughing i'm looking at 311
okay and
we've talked a little about a little bit
about anxiety attacks that we've had
yeah and the first one i ever had i
overheard this couple talking about
jerry o'connell and then i started
thinking about jerry o'connell and how
weird it is that he's so famous and then
my mind my mind just spun out and then
90 seconds later i'm like i can't see my
heart's beating
that's so that's the context that's my
first anxiety attack i've had like two
or three total okay but they're always
in restaurants or weirdly lowly lit
places like one time i had one in the
stadium at night okay it's the way the
light affects me and sometimes the way
my mind spins out on spools okay in an
unforeseen way right okay so
311 but you don't pass out no i don't
okay okay okay so it's 311 and i'm
thinking about uh three it's got three
hours 11 minutes that sucks i'm starting
to realize this tight space again
everybody's asleep it's like a night
flight oh
and then i think about oh yeah there's
that band 311 and then i think about oh
i remember when that band 311 was
popular everybody said it was a white
supremacist band because three eleven
three k is kkk right right and then i'm
thinking about the kkk and then i'm just
like whoops you know my brain sure is
now
falling out of my skull and i'm just
like [ __ ] ah and i get like a million
[ __ ] thoughts flying through my head
all uncontained and unthought through
okay and then i'm like well at least a
lot of time just passed and i look at
the flight map and there's three hours
and 11 minutes left okay so like i'm
losing my perception of [ __ ] time
yeah and i'm just like
but inside right right i'm not freaking
out on the outside i'm forgetting on the
inside because i'm a good person i don't
want to scare these people on the plane
yeah so i i'm actually like uh oh this
is gonna be an anxiety [ __ ] and usually
i have like you know whatever [ __ ]
xanax something around yeah somebody
with something even though i don't
usually have that sure
so i'm like somebody on the plane has to
have one maybe even if i ask the fighter
yeah yeah so i go to the back and i tell
this flight attendant look okay dude uh
yeah uh uh i'm i'm really sorry i'm not
gonna cause a scene i don't want to
scare you or anybody else but like i'm
on the i know myself i've had a couple
of these before in my life i'm on the
precipice of having an anxiety attack
and and uh uh i don't know what to do i
don't have any medication with me okay
okay so she's really really nice okay
and she says okay well let me see what i
can do and it seems like she's gonna
[ __ ] figure something out right yeah
so she goes to the front to the head of
the flight crew and and her and and one
of the head of the flight crew comes
back two women now okay okay they both
come back and she's talking to me about
what she can do is there anything yeah
and she's like well you know if maybe if
you just talk to me and i'm like
thanks right like i know what i [ __ ]
mean right you know
so sh so she's like okay okay you're not
you're not telling her what you might
need i am i'm like it would really help
me if somebody had some kind of valium
or xanax or anything like that you know
they can't do that though right
okay
so uh
so she's like okay okay and she's coming
up with suggestions super nice right
suck but she's being so nice yeah she's
clearly never had anxiety right she's
like what if we do a play right and i'm
just she's like you can pace around here
in the galley and i'm like i don't right
give a [ __ ]
but thanks you know what i mean right
but i'm like being nice but like short
you know i'm just like thanks but you
know i actually know what this is you
know right right and uh i know you and
yeah and so i'm like okay
she's like well what we could do if you
think it's worth it we could call see if
there's a doctor on the plane see if he
can talk to you right here she can talk
to you okay and i'm like normally you
know me i would never do that right yeah
yeah but i'm like i'm like my heart's
like about to walk out of my chest right
so i'm like you're really going through
it yeah dude and so i'm like i'm like
okay okay okay
and and they're like okay great
so nice okay wow so they call for a
[ __ ] doctor
this guy comes to the back of the plane
and he's like what's going on you know
and everybody's got a mask on except me
and they're like it's okay you don't
need a mask on i think it might have
contributed but i wasn't being like a
[ __ ]
shitty mega guy like i don't wear this
[ __ ] i was just like i think this might
have contributed to my anxiety because
i'm feeling like contained
okay i don't know so you you're saying
so you took it off let me take it off
got it all right is this air canada
flying from canada yeah legally they
have to you have to worry about got it
which sucks
and um
so the doctors all just as [ __ ] cool
just as great and they're like and he's
like so
it turns out he's a neurosurgeon at
cedars
okay so he's like my son has this exact
same thing happens all the time you guys
have a first aid kit right they're like
yes and he's like you guys have valium
and xanax and adivan in there right and
and she's like
yes and i'm like yes right why didn't
you say that dude well because she needs
a doctor clearance right exactly so
he's like get it out and he even now
he's like just give it to him yeah yeah
he's got to sign all these papers he's
being so [ __ ] great right right my
absolute hero cool okay cool so he
[ __ ]
he hooks me up and he's like he'll need
two but give him one and if it doesn't
if he's not feeling a lot better in 20
minutes give him the next one right okay
i take one feel a little bit better okay
good yeah good doing his job 20 minutes
later i'm like i'm still like my heart's
still racing it would be better i've
taken this drug many times right i've
been prescribed it and uh by doctors
yes exactly
and and he's like okay well she comes by
and she's like would you the head of the
flight team would you like that other
one i can see you seem a little bit
still maybe nervous yeah and i was like
that would be amazing thank you so much
she brings me another one okay
now i'm like okay well the edge is gonna
go
now here's where the story turns oh my
god the woman in the row in front of me
turns around and says
hi
so nice
hi i heard you were having an anxiety
attack i get them all the time would you
like some of my medicine
she doesn't know at all that i've gotten
medicine from the flight people already
okay which is already a lot it's not
like i'm going to go [ __ ] passing out
or right right but it's a big dose two
milligrams of that event is a lot that's
yeah okay
um so but me being me and not you yeah i
immediately say yes before she can even
stop asking
finish asking the question wow she gives
me a pill that i've never seen before
and
you already had the second one i know
right before this right before it so you
should have waited for it to say oh yeah
okay oh yeah all right so i should have
waited i shouldn't even have taken it
right
next thing i know
dude
i'm
coming to
standing above different people on the
plane
in the middle of conversations and all
of them are looking at me like this and
only i can see they're only their eyes
they're all like this
and they're they're scared we're really
confused i'm in the aisle standing over
them and every time i come to i realize
i'm scaring this person i don't know how
i got here i don't know what i'm saying
okay i don't know what i'm saying okay
okay hold on hold on i'm standing over
them okay looking down at them probably
really scary without a mask on right
saying things that i don't even know
what they are because i don't know what
i'm doing
there yeah yeah okay so i wake up when
i'm realizing i'm upsetting someone only
what
this happens
at least four times
one time dude
two of them i remember distinctly okay
one time
a guy is pushing me off of him
and i come too because he's physically
pushing me and i'm like
i'm being pushed by a guy who i don't
know who it is and i don't know what i'm
talking to him about and but then when i
come to i'm just me again so i'm like
dude i'm so
i'm so sorry i have no [ __ ] idea what
i'm doing i don't even know what i said
to you i don't know what i said you
whatever i [ __ ] said what i don't
know what it was and i'm sorry okay
the next one that i remember i'm
standing above this poor
middle-aged woman i'm sure a very nice
sweet person
she looks [ __ ] terrified and all i
know is that i come to wake up let's say
saying
remember that you you don't remember
that okay you don't remember that
and she's just like
like so scared you know what i mean and
i feel so bad because i'm the one
scariest person and i don't even know
how i did it right right okay so then
finally i'm back in my [ __ ] seat and
the guy next to me actually i mean
everyone on this plane was so nice the
guy next to me was so nice
i guess i gave him uh my my email
address at some point right oh my god
okay
so he emails me just to see how i'm
doing like the next day oh okay okay so
and you get off the plane everything's
okay yeah yeah dude i find the guy
picking me up the next day he was like
you were [ __ ] up what the [ __ ] you
know what happened last night and i was
like i told you he's like i know but
dude what the [ __ ] well i dropped you
off at a 7-eleven
i picked you up and took you to 7-eleven
you came out everyone in the 7-eleven
was like dying laughing
at you i was like i don't remember that
even a little bit right so uh
the guy who i was sitting next to him
and his wife they were coming back from
italy he's like
he emails me just to see how i am okay
right and i'm like oh dude i'm [ __ ]
great like i feel great thanks for
checking in how you doing like i
remember you're a really nice guy yeah
but i know what's up yeah yeah i mean i
know why he's just at your worst yeah
and so i [ __ ] i'm like hey do you you
know what i was doing right
and he was like yeah like yeah kind of
everybody knew her right oh my god and
like uh
i was like did i like do anything really
bad yeah yeah yeah and he was like
actually no it was just like you were
being like really weird and i was like
what was i doing
and he's like well i don't know because
i didn't hear all of it like no one did
but you at the one point the woman that
i was like do you remember that do you
remember that do you remember that yeah
uh
he was like you were asking if she
remembered
the the band pearl jam
and if she remembered the song daughter
and when she wasn't responding you
started singing it to her
yeah oh yeah
oh my god dude thank god i wasn't there
hmm thinking no one i know was there no
meander not fair town dude on the plane
to a stranger with no mask on looking up
at me [ __ ] terrified so no picture
can't well remind
me just like scaring everybody dude what
did the flight attendants do nothing
dude they let me run free because i
wasn't like
really doing anything i guess i mean
that's kind of harassment it is a
harassment dude and i [ __ ] feel bad
i feel bad
i mean i feel terrible dude okay okay so
hold on so all right so
holy [ __ ] dude and you don't but that's
crazy that that you can be standing up
doing stuff you don't even you're not
even aware and i'll tell you the
craziest part is that when i would snap
into it yeah i was just me again and i
remember all of that right so so the
fourth time it happened were you like
[ __ ] another one of these things again
because you knew what was happening dude
it was like what the [ __ ] like sit in my
chair [ __ ] oh wow dude like i'm
two people
dr jekyll and mr two people dude dr
jekyll and mr matt and the moral of
story is i'm two people
do you remember pearl j i'm like the
chris farley show you know like i'm
interviewing eddie better on the chris
farley show
the lady and then you walk up hey do you
remember pearl jam
uh do you remember daughter i i don't
know don't call me daughter what the oh
sorry ma'am
well that was the scariest part to them
where i just turn into somebody else
[Music]